Спекулювати на мові можуть або популісти,
або люди яким немає чим зайнятися.
Навіщо партія Зеленського атакує українську мову?
Скажу чесно, я ще ні з ким не зустрівся.
Ну, по-перше, мене і не запрошували
З якими проблемами до Вас можуть звернутися українці?
Я не зможу реагувати на порушення прав громадян
у конкретному кафе чи в конкретній маршруті.
Чи не є це ігнорування офісу, можливо Вас?
Про те чи потрібен українській мові захист, про російськомовні серіали
та про квоти на українському телебаченні, говоримо з Тарасом Кременем,
новим уповноваженим із захисту державної мови.
Доброго дня!
Лише масштабні мовні акції допомогли зняти
з розгляду законопроект Максима Бужанського,
який багато хто сприйняв як зазіхання на державну мову з боку влади.
Як гадаєте, навіщо партія Зеленського атакує українську мову?
Насправді  я мусив би не погодитись, що тільки політичними акціями
біля Верховної Ради вдалося зупинити
розгляд законопроекту про перенесення
переходу шкіл з російськомовного навчання
на українську мову з 2020 року.
Спекулювати на мові можуть або популісти,
або люди яким немає чим зайнятися.
Але тим не менш є Максим Бужанський, був його законопроект,
він належить до провладної партії “Слуга Народу”.
Суть в тому, що він є одним з народних депутатів, і для того, щоб документ набув
і для того, щоб цей документ набув чинності, потрібно 226 голосів.
Я розумію, що цих голосів не було і на момент, коли цей законопроект реєструвався.
Для мене важливо, що профільний комітет
з питань гуманітарної й інформаційної політики не дав голосів за цей документ.
І, зрозуміло, що Міністерство освіти і науки тримає проукраїнську позицію.
Він знайшов підтримку в гуманітарному комітеті Верховної Ради,
і його на той час очолював Олександр Ткаченко.
А нині він міністр культури...
Як далі співпрацювати можна?
Я думаю, що співпраця має бути, бо Міністерство культури та інформаційної політики -
це головний провідник в уряді, який відповідає за державну мовну політику,
і ми повинні звірювати годинника.
Пан Олександр підтримував іншу кандидатуру - Світлану Броннікову,
а тепер Ви будете з ним працювати, як бачите цю співпрацю?
Час розставляє все на свої місця, і мені здається,
що як і зі Святославом Літинським, так і зі Світланою Бронніковою
у нас багато спільних проектів, єдине, що потрібна їхня згода.
Президент Зеленський також казав, що мовні квоти треба переглянути.
Олександр Ткаченко - міністр культури - казав, що квоти добре, що вони є,
але потрібно їх переглянути, аби надати розвиток і поштовх зйомкам
серіалів та фільмів російською мовою, тому що це стимулює приватний бізнес.
Що ви думаєте про такий вид бізнесу?
Треба першу чергу спиратись на документи.
Я не бачив документа, який би виходив з офісу президента, чи профільного комітету.
Треба в першу чергу дивитись на документ, які стратегії він вирішує.
Але я проти таких документів, чи то проектів чи постанов,
які вступають у конфлікт із законодавством.
Не треба забувати, що понад 90% громадян України,
згідно з центром Разумкова, вважають себе українцями.
Не просто українцями за походженням, а громадянами України,
ідентичність яких дозволяє говорити таке.
Тому в жодному випадку ми не повинні забувати
про національні меншини і корінні народи.
Тобто такі серіали можуть бути?
Вони мають місце тільки тоді, коли ми говоримо мовою окремих документів.
Поки що це на рівні заяв і окремих гасел.
Олександр Ткаченко говорив, що сподівається, що офіс уповноваженого
найближчим часом запрацює і буде дієво працювати.
але він з Вами не зустрічався?
Мене в перші тижні моєї роботи запитують:
Ви вже зустрічались з прем'єром, Ви зустрічались з міністром?
Скажу чесно, я ще ні з ким не зустрічався.
Ну, по-перше, мене і запрошували, і мені запросити нема куди.
Бо фактично з коліс створюється секретаріат уповноваженого,
бо у нас не має ні штату, ні у приміщення,
ні фінансування, фактично, в мене ще немає права підпису.
Чи не є це ігнорування офісу, можливо Вас?
Я зважаю на те, що останні два тижні були напружені
не тільки в стінах Верховної ради але і в Кабміні.
Велика кількість проблем,
які збираються, їх треба вирішувати в окремих випадках
негайно і оперативно.
Я думаю, що такі зустріч відбудуться, звичайно.
Але так само як і мають зустрічатись люди такого рівня,
треба, звичайно, спілкуватись з людьми в регіонах.
Ви вже два тижні на посаді,
як виглядає ваш робочий день зараз?
Ці два тижні, оскільки я зараз в столиці,
це кропітка робота не тільки з добору людей,
персоналу, який працюватиме в секретаріаті уповноваженого із захисту державної мови.
Орган створюється наново.
З моменту, як закон проголосив
про необхідність створення офісу уповноваженого,
не зроблено фактично нічого.
Тому доводиться сьогодні не тільки шукати приміщення,
шукати алгоритми, шпарини, витягувати з українського законодавства…
Ви вже рахували який штат повинен мати офіс?
Відповідно до штату, який затвердив в Кабміні три тижні тому,
він складається з 50 осіб.
Це посада уповноваженого,
це голова секретаріату, відповідні відділи,
і ми плануємо запустити регіональне представництво.
Чи це буде за кущовим, так би мовити, принципом,
чи в кожній області буде по одному представнику…
Напевне, що того фінансового забезпечення, яке закладене,
не  буде достатньо для всіх 50 співробітників.
А який бюджет?
Бюджет треба уточнити, бо мені здається,
що з перерозподілом коштів на Сovid-19
може залишитись мінімум.
Потім хотілося б мати своє приміщення.
Я хочу звернутись до міністрів Кабміну,
прийміть уповноваженого із захисту української мови, ми зрештою робимо одну справу.
Нам треба провести закупівлі і придбати якісь елементарні меблі,
для того, щоби проводити прийом.
або організувати доступність для людей з особливими потребами.
Нам треба спілкуватись з регіонами і це, звичайно,
підтримка з боку органів місцевого самоврядування.
І ми повинні мати обличчя в особі наших міжнародних партнерів.
Бо, скажімо, в Європі в кожній країні є
та чи інша інституція, яка займається мовними проблемами:
чи це рівень Академії наук, чи рівень,  як аналогічно Україні, Уповноваженого...
А які Ви зараз бачите основні проблеми функціонування української мови?
Чи відрізняються вони від проблем, які є в Європі, де є схожі інституції?
Уповільнення в утвердженні державної мови затягнулось на десятиліття,
в країнах Балтії це все вирішувалось в інший спосіб і набагато швидше.
Бо є цінності, є пріоритети і, що найголовніше,
це збереження культури, традиції і мови.
Без мови не може бути ні засвоєння класичної літератури
ні самоідентифікації себе в цивілізованому вимірі.
Це ж саме можемо спостерігати і в інших країнах.
Бо я собі не уявляю, щоби громадянином Великої Британії чи Франції
стала людина, яка не знає а ні законів, а ні мови.
Державною не хочуть спілкуватись ті, хто і російської не знає.
Хто і мову своєї національної меншини знати не хоче.
Цей синдром малоросійства,
хохляцтва,
суржику,
який опановує в тому числі і вищі щаблі
української держави, вони повинні бути зупинені.
До Вас уже звертались мовні активісти, які б хотіли
очолювати в себе в області офіс омбудсмена?
Є орієнтовний перелік таких осіб, таких навчальних закладів.
Це публічні люди?
Так, звичайно, вони є лідерами громадської думки в певних регіонах.
Мені приємно, що Святослав Літинський - один із претендентів на Львівщині чи заході України,
маючи такий досвід, аби все-таки очолити, якщо він дасть на те згоду.
Є в Ужгороді декілька прекрасних людей, є в Миколаєві, Дніпрі, Чернігові.
Тому я вкотре звертаюсь до українців: хто має в собі сили і бажання -
давайте розглядати кандидатуру кожного з Вас.
Чи це буде посада, чи це буде підтримка ініціатив,  які будуть направлені
на підсилення ролі і рівня володіння державною мовою.
Давайте про практичність вашого офісу. З якими проблемами до Вас можуть звернутися українці?
З такими проблемами, коли  люди не переходять на українську в сфері обслуговування,
до Вас можуть звертатись?
Що стосується порушення прав громадян на отримання послуг державною мовою,
я хотів би пояснити, що кожен громадянин може реагувати на подібні виклики.
В кожному закладі чи сфері обслуговування, чи в громадському транспорті,
чи в органах самоврядування є гаряча лінія, чи книги скарг і пропозицій,
де можна залишити відповідні звернення.
Сьогодні популярно викладати скарги в соцмережі.
На даному єтапі проблема моєї суб'єктності обмежена тим,
що не працює офіс, тобто немає умов ці матеріали приймати
і давати відповідні звернення. Тому на цьому єтапі я готовий вирішувати
системні проблеми на рівні державних установ. Я не зможу реагувати
на порушення прав громадян в конкретному кафе чи в конкретній маршрутці.
Але в той же час кожен громадянин, якщо він підтримує державну мовну політику і мене
як мовного омбудсмена, я звертаюсь:
допомагайте підтримуйте і давайте цей досвід
боротьби за захист державної мови засвоювати разом.
Якщо вас обслуговують російською? Ви просите, аби перейшли на українську?
Звичайно, я звертаюсь: дівчата, хлопці давайте поважати себе.
Згадайте, який був спалах у соцмережах,
коли Макдональдс відмовився обслуговувати своїх клієнтів іншою,
крім української і англійською мов. Це абсолютно нормально і справедливо,
коли нерезидент української держави, який непогано заробляє, надаючи послуги,
і поважає українські закони. То чому ж українські підприємці -
приватні перевізники, дехто із сфери послуг ігнорують такими речами.
Тобто іноземці підтримують, захищають українське законодавство,  а ми - ні.
Якою мовою говорять у Вас в родині?
Моя родина дуже велика. Якщо говоримо за дружину і дочку, то говоримо українською мовою,
тому що для моєї дочки, яка першого вересня йде до першого класу,
принципово важливо мати мовні компетентності.
Але я не кажу, що вона не вміє говорити російською,
бо її ровесники спілкуються і російською в тому числі.
Першою мовною омбудменом стала Тетяна Монахова,
але через півроку пішла з посади, оскільки, за її словами, без секретаріату,
який тоді так і не створили, вона була безсила.
Що змусить Вас піти з вашої посади?
Відповідно до закону тільки смерть. Насправді ні.
Я не готовий сьогодні високий рівень довіри,
наданий кабінетом міністрів і українським народом, розміняти на особисті преференції.
Дякую Вам!
Дякую.